and i told ron howard i couldn't do the
movie
everybody seems to think that acting is
the best job ever but in the case of
these stars there were moments that made
them question their career choice so i
thought i should think about it for a
few days and just make sure actors and
actresses are usually proud of the craft
they turn out and why wouldn't they be
especially with all the effort they put
in though at times there are moments
where they question their decisions
sometimes the things that these stars
are required to do can cross the line
making things so difficult that they
almost quit the industry all together
[Music]
jennifer lawrence impressed audiences
with her role as katniss everdeen over
the course of four hunger games movies
but a particular scene in the final film
almost made her quit while filming the
sewer scene lawrence had to wear a
20-pound costume in extremely high
temperatures which required three weeks
of filming the process was so
excruciating that lawrence considered
quitting until changing her mind
that was a day of great sorrow
emma watson nearly walked away from
playing the fan favorite character
hermione several times while shooting
all eight films until the studio made
some accommodations to her schedule
while filming the scene where hermione
and ron destroy a horcrux in the water
she was required to partake in extensive
filming in extremely cold temperatures
when she was already soaking wet
i hate to sound whiny but it's horrible
this has definitely been the most
intense grueling period of filmmaking
i've ever done i definitely made the
right decision
zoe saldana has been a part of multiple
blockbuster franchises from the mcu to
avatar and star trek but among one of
the actresses first major roles was in
pirates of the caribbean the curse of
the black pearl a film which she nearly
quit seldana claimed that the aura on
the set of the disney film was so toxic
and elitist that she nearly quit the
business completely people disrespecting
me because they look at my number on a
call sheet and they think i'm not
important
jennifer lawrence had to use plenty of
blue makeup and prosthetics in order to
accurately portray the iconic x-men
character mystique over the course of
four movies though lawrence almost quit
the role before filming her fourth and
final outing as the character in dark
phoenix while initially lawrence wasn't
too bothered by the fumes and toxins in
her blue getup as she continued to
reprise the role it started to bother
her greatly now i'm almost 25 and i'm
like i can't even pronounce this and
that's going in my nose i'm breathing
that turns out they never had to do
eight hours of full-blown body pain ever
oh
many fans were disappointed in how
jeremy renner's hawkeye was used in the
first avengers film and apparently so
was renner himself renner didn't want
his character to be just a mindless
victim for loki and wanted marvel to
kill his character off though the studio
had other plans so he would no longer
have to play the role eventually the
creative minds at marvel opted to give
runner's character a more substantive
arc which led to the actor finally being
satisfied look it's not just you know
slinging arrows and flying with hammers
and that kind of stuff anya taylor joy
has made waves with her incredible
performance as beth harmon in the
queen's gambit taylor joy was unsure if
she could fit the bill when playing the
titular character in the jane austen
adaptation emma so i got jane austen's
emma as a job and that really panicked
me because it was a role that was
supposed to be beautiful from the offset
and i hadn't done that i'd played
creatures outsiders whatever at this
point taylor joy wasn't sure if she
liked the path her career was going and
considered quitting but changed her mind
as filming went on this was more an
opportunity for me to show that i am an
actor and i'm versatile
for jim carrey it was not just one scene
in particular that made him want to drop
out of ron howard's live-action
adaptation of dr seuss's the grinch
kerry quickly grew sick of the hours and
hours of time he had to endure in the
makeup chair in order to portray the
iconic green character as well as
putting on the frisbee-like eye lenses
which were certainly not comfortable it
was not until producer brian grazer
called up his friend from the cia to
help train carrie to better deal with
the makeup process after the visit
carrie decided to stay on board as the
christmas hating grinch
while filming the mcu sequel thor the
dark world jaime alexander who plays
thor's asgardian friend sif slipped and
fell while filming on an elevated
platform the injuries which included
dislocating her left shoulder herniating
a disc in her spine and chipping 11 of
her vertebrae were so severe that it was
unknown how long recovery would be and
whether or not she would even be able to
finish the film wait this is from doing
stunts yeah is that why you got into
hollywood i love it alexander entered
physical rehab for a month and was
fortunately able to return to set to
finish several fight scenes for the
sequel
jessica alba considered quitting the
industry altogether when playing the
invisible woman in the superhero sequel
fantastic four rise of the silver surfer
while filming a scene that required her
to cry she received notes from the
film's director that made her question
if she was good enough for the role he
told me it looks too real it looks too
painful can you be prettier when you cry
cry pretty jessica he was like don't do
that thing with your face just make it
flat we can cgi the tears in
anger rage
frustration
one of johnny depp's big breakout films
was his role in what's eating gilbert
grape opposite leonardo dicaprio depp
unfortunately had a rough time making
the film as it came really close to his
own personal upbringing depp almost quit
over the scene where his character had
to call the actress playing his mother a
bleached whale and didn't appreciate how
cruel his character was to his mother
dylan o'brien almost had to unwillingly
quit after a stunt gone wrong while
filming the maze runner the death cure
the incident led to o'brien having bone
fractures lacerations and a concussion
which led to the filming having to be
delayed for an entire year o'brien
remained persistent about returning to
the role for one last time
it wasn't easy you know
and once he was cured he jumped right
back in and even took on several other
action films as well such as american
assassin and love and monsters that was
awesome
oh i feel like tom cruise
michelle rodriguez was angered when
reading the script for the fast and the
furious when she learned that her
character letty was supposed to betray
her boyfriend dom and get with her
boyfriend's rival brian she believed
that an alpha girl would never leave her
alpha male lover for a simple pretty boy
and threatened the producers that she
would quit if they didn't do her
character justice the director
ultimately changed the script
introducing a new character mia to serve
as brian's new love interest
you may recognize stanley tucci for his
role in the hunger games or his role as
nigel in the devil wears prada tucci
landed an american award nomination for
his work in the lovely bones but the
disturbing nature of his character
almost led him to quit the movie tucci
went on to say that having to portray a
character who performs the heinous
actions that he does was painful it was
grueling because of the nature of the
character and the nature of the story
you can't do anything to make that any
easier
with star wars the force awakens being
her first ever major film daisy ridley
felt immense pressure while filming on
set as rey and almost walked away from
the role because of the mental stress
during filming director j.j abrams
called ridley's acting wooden and that
comment along with being the new face of
one of the most beloved franchises in
history caused her to panic and consider
quitting acting for good
thankfully in the end ridley stuck with
the role and ended up receiving rave
reviews for her work as rey in the star
wars sequel trilogy
even before the days of the internet a
lot of eyes were on michael keaton when
he was announced as the new batman while
some may expect donning the black bat
suit to be an experience of a lifetime
for keaton it was a nightmare putting on
the black suit triggered keaton's
claustrophobia which sent him in a panic
every time he had to put on the suit
i thought i don't know how i'm gonna do
this man i'm feeling really really
scared
even some of hollywood's biggest and
brightest stars almost walked away from
some of the roles that made them the
stars that they are known as today even
jennifer aniston almost quit acting
after starring in a project that she
felt was unprepared thanks for watching